musulmane aborder la politique avec un
homme que vous ne voyez pas souvent
parce qu'il a jusqu'à présent refusé les
projecteurs du moins ce domaine s'agit
du commandant cousteau aujourd'hui pour
l'une à l'antenne de ville accepte de
répondre aux questions que se pose avec
insistance un certain nombre de
militants écologistes que représente
assez bien du ce dans ce dessein alors
la première question comment vous êtes
oui ou non candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et bien je vais quand
même vous expliquer le cheminement de la
pensée dans ce disque des feature
difficile décision
j'ai reçu un nombre incroyable de
sollicitations par écrit un nombre de
lettres qui avoisine 40 milles qui en
fait se réduit à 25 mille parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui auraient créé cinq
ou six fois et même une fois quatorze
fois quand vous aime bien vous ruiner
mais vous seriez candidats en gros mais
ces gens là il faut quand même y en a
qui représentait des associations des
groupes les gens importants qui se bat
depuis des années pour l'écologie je ne
peut pas traiter sa part de son agent
malgré la réticence à m'intéresser aux
luttes politiciennes que j'ai toujours
manifesté leur insistance à peser pour
moi un cas de conscience 4 conscience
j'ai consacré trois semaines nous ne
faisons que ça pratiquement j'ai
interrogé tout le monde j'ai interrogé
les principaux candidats
j'ai interrogé les chefs des principales
formations
on est venu discuter avec moi chez moi
et ailleurs j'ai aussi interrogé oui
j'ai aussi interrogé en dehors de ces
lettres
ce qui m'intéressait de seles avait deux
lettres sur trois qui me disait soyez
candidat une mètres sur trois qui visait
non vous allez créer la division mais à
côté de ça j'ai interrogé d'état de
citoyens dans la rue des porteurs de
bagages des changes journaux
les cafetiers des chauffeurs de taxi etc
et c'est elle qui va intéresser et 95%
me disait vous n'allez tout de même pas
vous occuper de ça joue bon alors là
vous faites du respect non candidat eh
bien
je vais quand même vous avant de vous
donner ma réponse
allez je vais quand même je vais quand
même me dire que vous donne les
arguments qui avaient pour les arguments
qui avaient contré ans poursuivi un
petit peu ma pensée c'est quand même je
crois que c'est intéressant de savoir
pourquoi je prends une décision alors
les arguments pour c'était que ces
présidentielles donné l'occasion
d'exprimer au public avec la télévision
largement ouverte
les doctrines des écologistes et des
doctrines qui sont souvent mal comprise
par le public qui voit les gens les
écolos comme les gens à retourner aux
cavernes et c'est ce qui n'est pas vrai
nom est la deuxième argument c'était que
ça permettait de se compter 2 si on
avait un bon score que pourraient
influencer des plans établis
le premier argument est bon parce que
malgré le tohu bohu électorale
effectivement des gens auraient pu
s'exprimer
les arguments est un petit peu moins bon
parce que le compte des électeurs qui
votent écologiste n'a rien à voir avec
le nombre des véritables écologistes en
france en france tous les sondages
montrent qu'il y en a au moins 30% mais
des gens qui votent y en a 4 5 6 es tu
pour ça donc par conséquent il ya un
divorce complet entre le nombre d entre
soul et la france écologique réelle et
la france pour le gist légal ait fait
cela me donne politique
vous répondez poker et bien inventer ou
pas je vous donne les deux arguments
contre maintenant vous dira après
travailler tout de suite alors les
avions en compte c'est d'abord qu'à
l'origine pas l'intention d'être
candidat
quand les unes chercher ma candidature
crée effectivement une division
puisqu'il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés qui ont commande passée la
plantation depuis déjà longtemps un
candidat de plus ça aurait jeté le
discrédit et ma véritable vocation
finalement c'est 2
m'occuper de défendre la vie de défendre
l'eau ça une échelle globale ctf les
interlocuteurs valables sont pas les
gouvernements ce sont les organisations
intergouvernementales
c'est à dire là les communautés
européennes les nations unies
l'organisation africaine l'organisation
sud-américaine et c'est donc je crois
avoir compris vous vous présentez pas
alors tout bien pesé
j'annonce aujourd'hui officiellement
nous quoiqu'il arrive quelles que soient
les pressions qu'on fasse sur moi en
remerciant beaucoup tout ce qu'ils ont
fait cette pression je ne serai pas
candidat reconnaissez définitive est
définie c'est pas un caprice de star
saluer les noms d un petit peu lent
corps pour tous ces sujets oui alors
cette décision entraîne quand même un
certain nombre de conséquences
ça ne veut pas dire que je me
désintéresse du mouvement écologique en
france au contraire
donc si vous voulez la grande leçon pour
moi de cette méditation c'est de me dire
peut-être que tu ne fais pas assez
occupé de ton pays pendant ces dernières
années que voulu voler trop
par conséquent j'ai l'intention de
m'occuper plus des questions de mon pays
à l'avenir que je n'en suis occupé dans
le passé alors et renforcer cette action
française l'écologie en même temps
j'aiderai les mouvements écologiques aux
présidentielles justement vos lombardie
pour qui vous allez voter au river la
relève ne me demandez pas ça de la
parole est aux écologistes c'est eux
mêmes qui désignent leur candidat et je
suivrai la discipline c'est à dire que
je soutiendrai leur candidat c'est à
dire l'art dit oui alors si vous voulez
j'espère que très rapidement une union
sera fait sur un seul nom je crois que
ça va se faire et saison laquelle plutôt
lequel priori selon la presse vous
pensez
non je vous pose la question et aux
écologistes et je le soutiendrai quelle
que soit leur candidat je le soutiendrai
et en même temps j'ai
je les appuierait et j'essaierai
également d'éviter certains excès de
parole qui donnent une mauvaise image de
l'écologie profonde dont cet homme là il
faut qu'ils aient des signatures pour
l'instant alors non sans signature ces
signatures
c'est l'occasion je vais très bref mais
donnez-moi là l'occasion de dire ce que
je pense je pense que le système des 500
signatures nous ramène à napoléon iii
c'est somme toute l'élection au deuxième
degré c'est vraiment très très mauvais
au produit mot pratique tueur préférait
si on voulait faire une barrière ce qui
est logique que on demande par exemple
aux candidates de rassembler 200 300
mille signatures de citoyens de dire que
la loi actuellement ensemble par
conséquent 500 signatures de maires
alors je profite de cette occasion pour
lancer un appel solennel aux maires de
france ceux qui hésitent encore à des
leurs signatures au candidat écologiste
devrait bien pensé qu' ils donnent leurs
signatures a des idées
ils ne donnent pas leur signature à une
personnalité
par conséquent qu'ils fassent leurs
examens conscience six ans en faveur la
protection de la nature et
l'environnement qu'il donne qui
soutiennent le candidat écologiste et au
deuxième jour entre les grands candidats
giscard mitterrand chirac de break est
ce que alors nous allons pas nous attend
mais millar est plus étroit risque un
autre non non écouter tous les curieux
sont d'accord pour renforcer les
questions contre lesquels nous nous
battons
c'est à dire quatre grands partis sont
d'accord pour renforcer l'énergie
faire voler concorde et c'est là qu'ils
sont des choses très bien entendu au
point de vue technologique mais qui
présente des dangers pour la population
qui sont impossibles dans le cadre d'une
caire et des côtes économique
catastrophique dans le carcan corps j'ai
pris encore plusieurs fois c'est un
avion merveilleux mais ça ne tient pas
debout au point de vue d'un point de vue
économique il l est les contribuables
paient les voyages des riches
privilégiés alors par le mouvement de ce
que 22 combats maintenant qui va pas été
uniquement électoral de se connaître
votre combat écologique pour la suite je
vais me sall et je me suis battu je me
suis battu et je continuerai à me battre
et là où les désastres arrive par
exemple en méditerranée en 1900 il ya 31
ans exactement nous
roth du véron au large de marseille 3e
marseille nous visitions ça c'est en
noir et blanc parce qu'à l'époque nous
filmer en noir et blanc c'était bourré
du poisson la vie était intense là la
flore était intense également je viens
ici tes cordes qui ont complètement
disparu des mérous il rappelé
et les poissons de passage y en a très
peu aujourd'hui mais quand nous sommes
revenus 31 ans plus tard et cette fois
quand nous avons voulu filmer en
couleurs dans cette grotte
nous avons été complètement sidéré de
voir le désastre écologique c'est-à-dire
une autre ayant une première dans un
désert vous voyez là en 1944 1
j'avais tous et tous ces poissons de
toutes sortes dans la grotte elle-même
différentes vous allez reconnaître en
couleurs et qui sera vide au même
endroit près d'un votant même endroit là
nous aurions des mérous qui veut toucher
qui venaient jouer avec nous et après ce
que cette période
clp la force qu'on a ressenti celle sur
les poissons il ya plus de poissons plus
rien nous sommes premiers résidents
pendant longtemps
alors d'où ça vient ça vient évidemment
de pollution mais ce vient aussi de
destruction mécanique et la question est
très grave
l allure méditerranée elle a lu aux
caraïbes etc notre organisation se
battra aux points chauds où qu'ils
soient dans le monde entier bien que
l'on je remercie d'avoir donc un autre
c'est en direct devant nos caméras que
vous ne serez pas en hiver je ne serais
pas contre prochaine élection
présidentielle selon ce soir